en direct avec nous j'ai un vestiaire
analyste géopolitique et fondateur du
média web le monde décrypté younès belle
fellah économiste et spécialiste du
monde arabe
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france on évoque plus de 6500
migrants qui seraient décédées sur les
chantiers du qatar depuis 2010 d'où
vient-il et comment leur pays d'origine
réagi style face à cette situation
lyonnaise mais le félin bonsoir je crois
que grâce en fait à la coupe du monde
qu'on arrive à découvrir et à dévoiler
des choses qui ont été caché pendant des
années des années au qatar dans ce qu'il
fait là maintenant on découvre qui a une
situation catastrophique parce que il ya
la pression internationale
derrière ce sujet concernant la question
des travailleurs étrangers
sachant bien que le qatar depuis 2010 ne
cesse pas de dire qu'elle va faire des
réformes en termes de droit de travail
en termes de salaires en termes de
protection des travailleurs étrangers
mais en fin de compte ils font ils font
rien du tout et donc ce qui fait que les
rapports soient de amnesty international
ou bien de tout récemment les articles
de deux gardiens évoque effectivement
qui a vraiment un grand problème en
termes de protection des travailleurs
étrangers
l'abus la discrimination est également
la question de l'organisation en fin de
compte du travail c'est-à-dire tout ce
qui concerne les contrats et droit et
droit de travail je crois que en fin de
compte le qatar mobilise énormément
d'argent pour soigner son image à
travers l'achat de certains politiciens
de certains journalistes de faire des
campagnes médiatiques à droite et à
gauche et d'acheter des lobbys et des
think tanks en france en suisse et en
belgique
mais en fin de compte ne fait aucun
effort en matière de développement des
droits des droits de l'homme et surtout
en fin de compte la protection des
travailleurs étrangers dans un pays qui
est constituée en fin de compte par dans
sa population par 90% des étrangers au
qatar ya seulement trois cent mille
personnes qatari et et le reste sont des
étrangers qui construit et qui se paie
ce pays maintenant la sphère et dévoilé
grâce à la halle à la coupe du monde
m'ayant on en douterait affaire dont on
n'a pas parlé parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on efface ont en quelque
sorte devant ce pays à une exonération
parce que depuis plusieurs années où on
parle de certains à faire contre des
étrangers ans rappelle bien de la sphère
de l'entrepreneur français jean pierre
moreau j ai également on se rappelle
également de certaines affaires comme la
sphère de diplomate qatari a à bruxelles
qui est d'ailleurs actuellement son
ambassadeur à paris un accusé dans une
affaire au meurtre de 19 personnes et
étrangers au qatar est également la
faire par exemple du frère de l'émir du
qatar qui accusé par incitation au
meurtre à à washington dans ce qui fait
que c'est plusieurs affaires donc le
problème c'est pas un problème en fin de
compte d'une affaire de coupe du monde
mais je crois que c'est un problème de
comportement d'état un comportement
méthodique qui exonère homme qui cherche
en fin de compte avec préméditation de
ne rien faire en matière de
développement des droits de l'homme et
également de la question de droit du
travail pour revenir sur cette coupe du
monde 2022 au qatar concernant ces
travailleurs étrangers la situation
n'est quand même pas totalement nouvelle
en entend parler depuis plusieurs mois
on appelle ce sentiment que la
communauté internationale réagisse
tellement j'ai un l'espère écoutez je
pense qu'il faut être très très prudent
parce que si on parle de lobby pro
qatari peut-être pouvons-nous parler de
lobby anti qataris
donc il faut être très très prudent à le
qatar vient de reconnaître 37 ou 39
comme vous l'avez précisé dans votre
reportage décès au cours des travaux
l'autre chiffre annoncé est de plus de
6000 morts n'est ce pas donc voyez vous
on voit déjà dans ce genre de situation
des exagérations a vraisemblablement
possible il y a eu déjà des événements
mondiaux sportif au qatar championnats
du monde championnats du monde
d'athlétisme en octobre 2019
mais peut-être que l'athlétisme
représente une moindre caisse de réseau
n'est ce pas vis-à-vis des médias
internationaux donc là on s'appuie sur
la résonance du football pour peut-être
essayer de monter de façon un peu
extrême la situation et d'autre part il
faut voir dans quel cadre à cette ces
éléments evènement pardon se déroule il
y a un an on aura eu cette discussion à
cet échange agréable et et bien et le
qatar était un as au bond n'est ce pas
des états du golfe il avait été mis de
côté
rupture des relations diplomatiques
arrêt des transferts de biens et
personnes entre l'arabie saoudite les
états du golfe et le qatar maintenant
depuis quatre mois il y a à nouveau
réunion dé tous les états donc du golfe
persique et de la confédération des
états du golfe et je crois que là il
faut aussi en tenir compte il y à un
apaisement à l'extérieur du qatar donc
il faut inscrire cet apaisement dans
cette situation vous abordiez l'enjeu la
question l'enjeu économique de ce
mondial du football au qatar lyonnaise
belle fait là alors on entend des appels
au boycott est ce qu'il pourrait
réellement conduire à l'annulation du
mondial tout d'abord elle l'enjeu pour
le qatar n'était pas un enjeu économique
et le qatar est un pays qui est
extrêmement riche mais l'enjeu pour le
qatar c'était à mon jeu politique c'est
à dire vendre le cadre d'une politique
de soft power le qatar essaye de faire
une puissance en fin de compte dont la
région à travers l'investissement soit
dans les médias l'organisation de
certains l événement dont notamment la
coupe du monde qui donne une légitimité
on va dire à pas seulement sportive mais
également une légitimité de rayonnement
d'image pour le pour le pays mais ce que
les dirigeants du qatar n'ont pas
compris c'est que on peut faire des
choses avec l'argent mais il faut
également une transformation du pays à
travers des réformes institutionnelles
là dessus je dois également souligné que
ce genre de pratique contre les
travailleurs eux étrangers il n'existe
pas seulement au qatar mais existe
pratiquement dans toute la région du
golfe cela c'est juste pour répondre au
monsieur est également
la deuxième des choses c'est le fait de
comprendre en fin de compte le
mécontement comprendre le fait qu'il ya
des demandes de boy quand on se rappelle
quand vous avez dit de certains
demandent de boycott qui ont été cités
en angleterre en 2000 en 2018 des
boycotts qui sont cités par certains
sportifs concernant la question des
ouïghours en chine et c'est une pratique
qu'ils courront dont le monde de sport
on ne peut pas empêcher en fin de compte
à un sportif de prendre une position
surtout quand il s'agit d'un
comportement d'état qu'il veut pas cher
des réformes et donc c'est ça la ccsa la
problématique en fin de compte
vis-à-vis du vis-à-vis du qatar en même
temps certainement c'est pas c'est
certainement ce n'est pas la seule à
faire pour mettre un petit peu le
contexte géopolitique ce n'est pas la
seule à faire là où le cac avait épinglé
c'est la question de travailleurs
étrangers
mais c'est également il y en a d'autres
à faire il ya la question de financement
des islamistes et et de terrorisme son
comportement dans la dans la région du
golfe et dans la région du du monde
arabe
ces investissements à l'étranger et
l'utilisation de ses investissements
pour une ingérence eau pour l affluence
dont le cas également en france les
investissements du qatar dépasse 40
milliards d'euros avec une exonération
d'impôts concernant les investissements
et immobilier et tout ça se fait bien
évidemment à travers soi du lobbying
soit de la corruption du favoritisme
l'achat de certains politiciens
l'organisation du 2e forum et
l'invitation de plus de 200 personnes
françaises chaque année deux leaders
d'opinion ce sont là il pratique du
qatar qui amène en fin de compte à
gagner l'organisation de de certains
événements pour soigner les matches j'ai
regardé ses jeux vesper après les propos
de votre contradicteur est ce que vous
direz qu'en terme de soft power locateur
a réussi avec la préparation de ce
mondial de football dans quelle mesure
est ce qu'un tel événement peut faire
évoluer un pays je me méfie beaucoup à
des idées je me méfie beaucoup de
l'émotion dans l'analyse géopolitique
il faut donner priorité au fait et on
évoque les travailleurs on découvre que
l'homme on est droite on évoque les
droits de l'homme regardons les droits
de la femme n'est ce pas dans les
championnats d'athlétisme à doha en 2019
il y avait nombre de représentants de
femmes du monde entier dans des tenues
de sport athlétique donc avec des jambes
nues et le qatar a accepté
n'est ce pas donc il y à cette volonté
aussi cette possibilité d'intégration
progressive très récemment à une équipe
de beach volley vous savez ce
volley-ball que l'on joue sur les plages
où les femmes sont aussi très peu vêtues
et bien l'équipe à l'équipe allemande
avait décidé de ne pas venir parce qu'on
leur demandait de porter une tenue plus
protégés est finalement le qatar a
accepté de laisser les joueuses
allemandes a joué dans la tenue du beach
volley donc voyez vous vos la défaite
voilà des observations on ne part pas
dans l'émotion part pas dans la diatribe
le politique
je pense que là on est dans une volonté
à de part et d'autre dans le monde
d'intégration à on se souvient des
diatribes aussi quand un saoudien été
nommé à la tête de la commission des
droits de l'homme de l'onu regardons
l'évolution des droits de l'homme en
arabie saoudite depuis quelques années
du droit des femmes qui peuvent conduire
qui sont dans les conseils municipaux
qui peuvent se déplacer à l'étranger qui
peuvent à fonder des sociétés donc voilà
il y à une nécessité d'inclure pour
progresser et non pas d'exclure pour
laisser les populations dans le
conservatisme pour vous était donc une
bonne idée de laisser le qatar a
organisé le mondial de foot 2022
je pense que nous avons des amis qatari
qui investissent beaucoup d'argent pour
que une certaine ville qui s'appelle
paris capitale de la france puisse avoir
un très grand club de football et que le
psg a puisse devenir un jour le champion
d'europe de football et avoir un
rayonnement mondial
donc si le qatar nous aide
peut-être pouvons-nous aussi apprécié et
dire au qatar et bien à mettez tout les
cas
nécessaires pour faire de beaux
championnats du monde de football en
2022 et au plan sportif à younes belle
fait là est ce que l'attribution du
mondial de foot au qatar vous semble
cohérent avec un l'esprit sportif que
dit vouloir la fifa moi je crois qu'il
faut multiplier les fort de la pression
politique et médiatique contre contre le
qatar pour changer son comportement son
comportement d'état parce que le
problème là dessus c'est pas des
pratiques exceptionnelles et
particulières qui sont liées à une
personne ou une autre mais c'est un
problème au niveau de loi au niveau de
la juridiction on va dire du qatar sa
demande comment un pays qui veut
organiser ce genre d'événement qui se
présente comme étant une puissance
régionale alors qu'il n'a pas un projet
elle démocratique sachant bien que le
qatar par exemple à essayer d'exporter
elle a la demo le modèle démocrates en
fin de compte donc plusieurs pays arabes
mais je veux pas l'appliquer enfin en
fin de compte au qatar le même problème
se pose où se posent au niveau de la
question de l'ex de droit d'expression
fin de compte parce qu'on trouve que les
médias du qatar qui existe partout dans
le monde avec différentes langues n'ont
jamais parlé de cette question de
travailleurs étrangers et concernant la
la la coupe la coupe du monde donc
effectivement je crois qu'il faut
multiplier ce genre de pression et qu'il
faut que les les états ou les
gouvernements prennent une position
claire à clair clair là dessus parce que
ce jour 2 de laxisme en matière soit
d'incitations fiscales d'accueil de
certains investissements d'utilisation
ou des détournements d'argent ne peut
pas amener un changement de comportement
dans cette région qui est une région
extrêmement importante et là bien
évidemment je fais pas je fais pas
l'exception du qatar mais je considère
que tous les pays en fin de compte des
du golfe son besoin de chèvre des
réformes concernant droit de travail
concernant la question de droite
justement alors justement j'ai un
vestiaire un tout dernier mot assez
rapidement si vous le voulez bien parce
que le temps file à quel serait selon
vous quelles peuvent être les retombées
positives pour la population au qatar 2
l'organisation de cet événement d'être
inclus dans le monde d'être de faire
partie de la planète bleue n'est ce pas
plus vous mettez un pays de côté plus
vous le mets l'ostraciser plus vous le
critiquez est bien plus vous avez une
situation conservative tous ces procès à
vatry cependant qui va s'enkyster qui va
s'alourdir
plus vous exposer un pays est bien plus
vous l'amener à s'ouvrir à illies a
actuellement une dizaine de projets de
création de golf n'est ce pas en arabie
saoudite percevoir apporter aussi des
nouveaux championnats la présence de
femmes dans le sport donc eh bien c'est
là c'est la même chose
il pourra y avoir peut-être après au
qatar un championnat du monde de
football féminin et ça c'est extrêmement
important pour l'évolution des sociétés
sur le long terme
merci beaucoup à tous les deux messieurs
j'ai un respect analyste géopolitique et
fondateur du média web le monde décrypté
younes el fellah économiste spécialiste
du monde arabe
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir sur
arte france